we have had a number of significant
events in recent weeks the president's
visit to Ukraine that President
zelenski's visit to London
and
last week we had the Secretary General
of NATO
confirming President Biden's prediction
that this will be a long war and I
wonder if I could just start by asking
you what alternative scenarios can you
envisage for the outcome of this war
that would be acceptable and in
particular
can you envisage any acceptable
circumstances which would leave Russia
in possession of any occupied Ukrainian
territory as part of a peace settlement
well thank you for having me sir Bernard
and I'll do my best to keep the answer
short so we can indeed um end on time
and get everyone in quickly on Ukraine I
think the simple answer to your question
Health really is it's for Ukraine to
decide what is acceptable to them it's
not for anyone else to dictate to
Ukraine our job as I see it is to put
them in the strongest possible position
to have that conversation at a time of
their choosing to ensure that they can
win this conflict and in the immediate
term my priority has been to accelerate
and intensify our support to Ukraine
with the provision of particular
capabilities to ensure that they can
have decisive advantage on the
battlefield uh over the coming months
and that's what our allies I also know
are committed to do I spoke to President
Biden about that and indeed president
macron when I saw them recently we're
all aligned on that strategy we've taken
a lead in fact in that strategy in the
UK and that's what the priority is for
now
um that would seem to be a no to the
answer in that case that if it's up to
Ukraine and your crime rate if you claim
that they want Crimea back as well we
would back them on that again this is
for Ukraine to decide our job is to put
them in the strongest possible position
to have those conversations at the time
that is appropriate second the budget
allocated extra money for defense uh
which I think the vast majority of
people most welcome but most of this
vital support has gone to support them
mod nuclear Enterprise
Ukraine urgently needs increased
supplies of weapons and ammunition if it
is to hold the current Russian offensive
and to drive Russia from its territory
the Secretary General of NATO has warned
that the whole of Europe needs to
replenish and renew weapons and munition
stocks and Supply chains to support the
long war in Ukraine so can you explain
please prime minister how will the UK
increase its weapons and Munitions
acquisition South both to replenish our
national essential stocks and
simultaneously maintain supplies to
Ukraine at the rate which they are
needed well there's two separate things
Savannah one is the support we give to
Ukraine that is incremental to the mod's
budget that was 2.3 billion last year
and again this year we said we will meet
or exceed that same amount and so that's
the support we're providing second only
to the United States in terms of the
military support that we're giving
Ukraine and then the mod
budget was increased by 5 billion pounds
at the budget and that came on top of
the 560 million pounds uplift that they
received at the Autumn statement the
breakdown of the five is three for
broadly the nuclear Enterprise and two
for stockpiles and Munitions coming on
top as I said of the half a billion at
the Autumn statement and something that
I know the defense secretary warmly
welcomed at the time
but the money so far allocated
does not replenish the stocks we've
already given to Ukraine and does not
reinvigorate our supply chains in order
to support the supply of weapons needed
to both replenish our own stocks and to
continue supplying recurring so we are
doing both we are providing extra
financial support as I said second only
to the Americans last year and this
directly to Ukraine we are
simultaneously increasing the mod's
budget both to strengthen its nuclear
Enterprise and
um to increase our own stoppiles I would
make the the general observation as well
you know wouldn't necessarily see it as
a negative that the stock our own
stockpiles have been drawn down for the
simple fact that if you think about what
are those weapons for I mean they were
ultimately there to degrade and deter
primarily a Russian aggression they are
being used to do exactly that they're
just being used by the ukrainians so in
one sense even though the stockpiles are
lower they are being used for the
purpose of which they are intended and
degrading the capabilities of an
adversary in the process so yes we will
rebuild them over I'm really the
constraint is the supply chain capacity
which is not something that we alone
face or all our European Partners face
the same supply chain constraints and
that's something that we are all
collectively grappling with but the
money's been put in as I said
incrementally for the mod on top of the
money for Ukraine
I'm finally prime minister my last
question and this thread there was a
very notable
sino-russian Summit last week what
conclusions should we draw
from this Summit and I don't think
you've said anything about this yet
so I you know my my observations on it
are you know whilst we welcomed and I
did Welcome China's support for
Ukraine's territorial Integrity as part
of the various things that they said I
think their abstention on voting for a
resolution it does little for their
credibility as a neutral party in this
you know I'd encourage president XI as
we've said to engage directly with
President zielinski on any particular
peace proposal that China is interested
in putting forward and that exactly is a
conversation I've had with President
zlinski as well China should would do
well to engage directly with Ukraine on
that you know more broadly it's clear
that Russia is dependent on China
for various reasons that are that are
obvious and again would ask president XI
to use his influence with Putin to urge
him to end this war and and withdraw
from Ukraine as a precondition to any
negotiations
um you're not supporting China's request
for a ceasefire no rather as I said that
there were various points in their peace
proposal and their support for Ukraine's
territory and integrity is indeed
welcome but as I said their actions
elsewhere and the other things they said
as I said undermine their credibility as
being a neutral party in this and you
know so we were as as we have urged with
colleagues that other countries for
China not to supply Russia with weapons
and to ask them to use that influence
with Russia to try and bring an end to
this conflict